so using this very simple notation uh
what can we do with it well we can solve
some problems so why don't we tackle
this one together I'll give you a moment
to jot down the critical details but
we've got a sphere
I've defined a radius for you to it's a
strange sounding radius but trust me
that I'm trying to make the numbers nice
for us in the future so square root of
26. we'll just consider a simple one
centered at the origin for now and then
you get given two points p and Q
that apparently uh cut through the line
PQ apparently cuts through the sphere so
there's going to be a couple of points
of intersection between the sphere and
this line PQ all right
so in fact if you wanted to draw kind of
uh you know some rough version of this
I'm not going to try and draw a a sphere
here but there's my my 2D diagram of my
sphere and then I'm cutting through I
don't know where p and Q are maybe p is
here maybe Q's there Q could even be
inside the circle actually it's not too
hard to work out if you wanted to where
the pnq are inside because you can work
out how far they are from the origin but
p and Q constitute a line and then what
I'm really looking for is where are
these two points where there's
intersection with the Spheres surface do
you understand the premise
yeah okay so now my question to you is
um how do we go about this so before I
put pen to paper I would love to hear
your thinking on this is a question
which uh we're gonna spend some time on
because there are several steps to it so
we want to break that down right so can
anyone suggest what might be a good
first step we're not actually going to
do the step I just want to work out the
path before we do any working what might
be the first thing you want to do to
start solving this question
probably want to eat from some sort of
like General equation because if you
want to use maintenance
yeah yeah okay excellent so I'm hearing
a few different ideas there right so
um you started talking about having a
general equation so we can equate them
each other so you're thinking back to
the fact that in two Dimensions if we
were trying to find points of
intersection and that's what this says
right
it doesn't use the phrase points of
intersection but where you meet the
sphere surface that's what you're
looking for you want two equations and
you just solve them simultaneously right
so we want two equations and then Mrs
Iles you said we want the equation of
the sphere which is sort of what we're
just talking about up above what's the
other equation that we need
because I actually don't have any
questions at all in this question
yeah I need I need pq's equation right
so what I'm going to do this is me
thinking with you right now okay
um I'm going to first maybe work out the
equation of line PQ because we can
review the fact of how we find the
equations of a line so that's the first
thing I'm going to do
then the second thing I'm going to do is
I'm going to say well okay what's the
equation of the sphere
and then I'm going to solve those
simultaneously so just think about this
for a moment right
once you solve this simultaneously
you're solving equation one the line and
equation two the sphere but what you're
going to get like remember the equation
of a line in general it'll be something
like uh R equals or maybe I'll use l
because um
we just talked about how R is dangerous
to put in this context
um can you help me remember what's the
general form of the equation of a line
it's got two pieces to it
the magnitude of the vector
um that's your like
this is
yeah okay very good so there's a couple
of vectors involved it's a vector
equation right so um I Heard a u so that
what we do you remember what we call
this this is getting onto the line so
this is what we call the position Vector
right and then we've got Lambda and
there's a second Vector here which tells
us which way we're facing so what do we
call that again not the position vector
Direction Vector very good now think
about this right we're going to solve
this equation here
this one here the line PQ and we're
going to solve it simultaneously with
the equation of the sphere so what
you're going to get is something in
terms of Lambda like you're going to get
a Lambda out of this in fact you might
get two lambdas right because I'm
expecting I'm anticipating there's a
couple of points of intersection so then
what do you do with those lambdas like
the lambdas are not the solution right
what do I do with those
right
yeah they're gonna those
those I'm gonna need to substitute the
lambdas into something and there's going
to only be one equation which has
lambdas in it right which equation is
that
come on yeah the lion right the sphere
is independent of Lambda we don't need
that so I'm going to substitute the
whatever I get from step three I'm going
to substitute that into line PQ okay so
obviously you don't need to usually
write this when you're you know solving
a question but because I've done lots of
these questions before I have this sort
of one two three four it's an algorithm
if you like set of steps to get the
answer I've got them kind of tucked away
in the back of my mind but I think it's
really helpful too especially because
these questions are relatively new to us
to articulate it so we don't get lost as
we're going through the question like
what do I do next where am I okay so now
we've charted our course and you know
eventually you'll get to a point where
you don't need to write that down you
can just do it intuitively but let's
have a go so I'm going to do step one
which is for line PQ now you got two
coordinates right so when I'm trying to
work out what P the line PQ is the first
thing I want to think about is what's
the direction Vector the the v as it
were that's going to be
um going into my equation right so I'm
going to work out what PQ is can you
guys help me out are you good enough to
go straight to the calculation or should
we write some extra working to help us
well it would be five minus three I plus
three plus one uh you're giving it to me
so you're giving it to me in component
form aren't you no why didn't I do that
yeah yeah no no don't don't apologize I
started writing it in calm form because
I'm lazy but um let's I I think it's
good it's actually very important um
even the component form is not what I
instinctively go to because I just have
to write extra stuff it is really
important that you can like comfortably
use all of them so let's let's just run
with it right so you said five minus
three I uh can you keep on going for me
what's next and then it's three plus one
J
uh plus negative four plus two okay well
done okay fantastic so what we were
doing there obviously was it was oq and
you're taking away op so there is a lot
going on there because you're applying
the negative at the same time but you've
done a great job right so well done
let's tidy that up so it looks to me
like I'm getting 2i
plus 4J
plus uh or minus rather 2K does that
sound all right
yeah okay now this is um this is PQ
right and this is uh the only Vector
that can be PQ but I just want you to
stop and think right what is the purpose
of us working that out like why is PQ
important to me
that's the direction yeah very good now
this is important right because I could
just take this answer and keep going and
I would get a right answer it would be
fine right but remember that there's an
infinitely there there's an infinite
number of different equations that are
all line PQ this is the only Vector that
is p to cube the interval but the the
line PQ which goes forever right it can
use any direction Vector that is
equivalent to this one now what do we
mean by equivalent like what could can
you give me another example of a vector
that would still be just as good as PQ
yep any any scalar multiple of PQ will
do the job right 2pq would work one and
a half p q would work minus PQ would
also work so because I'm using it so as
a direction Vector right what this tells
me is
um I might as well just pick the
simplest scale of multiple of PQ just to
make things easy for me right so if you
got if you were working um out you know
uh a fraction in a in a derivative right
and you saw something like 3x on six
that's still right but you wouldn't
write like immediately you would
instinctively simplify that wouldn't you
and you would just say okay these two
are equivalent and I can just keep going
so I want you to think now what would be
a more convenient scalar multiple of
this to use for my direction vector
so I said again you were a bit garbled
altogether
I
have a um
yeah fantastic I'm going to use half PQ
as my scalar multiple to you to use a my
direction Vector just because it's
easier okay so that's kind of the
equivalent of um yeah simplifying a
fraction as it were it's just it's a bit
sneaky because you know the question
didn't say it's a fraction simplify but
it's because we know we're using it as a
direction Vector that we can do it okay
fantastic so now I'm just about finished
with um part one of my question because
I can now say that line PQ maybe I'll
just use l
is equal to uh well I can use either of
uh p and Q as my position Vector right
let's just use p
three negative one negative two
here comes the Lambda that was mentioned
before and then we just decided what's
that one two negative one
okay so far so good how are you feeling
at the moment
okay happy times so now we're up to step
two what we want is an equation for the
sphere now
um we I've given you a relatively simple
one here right so remember the sentence
of the origin so therefore what's going
to go on the left hand side there's
really not that much actually
x squared I mentioned uh
yep so there's magnitude um I'm just
going to go straight for the vector
equations so in fact I can just
arbitrarily just say hey sum sum Vector
right and then I'm equal to my radius
what was the radius in the question
yep square root 26. now uh believe it or
not that's it that's that's all those
step uh step two
um it's it's finished at that point uh
because the equation of a sphere is
beautifully simple that's part of why we
um wanted to go in this direction but
now I I have to sort of expand on this
right because I need to solve this
simultaneously so remembering it might
be helpful to write this as x y z right
this is actually equal to the square
root of 26. when I go to solve
simultaneously the thing that I'm
solving simultaneously is this equation
I just wrote
with this one up here from that first
step right so you actually need to be a
bit careful here because you've got for
your X and your Y and your Z I've got an
equivalent X and Y and Z from The Lion
so here's the X don't forget there's a
Lambda hiding in there here is the Y
and then here is the Zed you've seen me
do this before right